une barque sur un lac deux hommes un
pêcheur l'auteur de ce tableau gérard
guerrier hemani quoi il participe au
salon pour la sixième fois
j'appelle les jeunes généralement des
paysages les paysages les rendent
souvent sur des voyages je prends une
photo d'un incident une photo du village
teint là c'est intéressant d'avoir
parfois des et compliments et d'autres
soient pas mais non il faut faut pas
avoir peur de montrer ses heures et je
recommande aux peintres de faire les
expositions même s'ils sont pas très
sûrs d'eux ça vaut vraiment la peine
comme gérard guerrier 22 autres artistes
exposent ils présentent chacun quatre
tableaux le salon des peintres de magny
les hameaux est organisé tous les deux
ans c'est une exposition de peintres
amateurs de manille et de sa région dont
il ya des gens qui viennent de buc de
versailles et de voisins on ne
sélectionne pas on accueille tous ceux
qui veulent participer ce que on estime
que chacun a droit d'exposer son art
donc on ne sélectionne pas natures
mortes réaliste au abstraite
les oeuvres sont à découvrir jusqu'au
dimanche 26 mars